tropical forests are one of the world's
most important carbon sinks absorbing
over one-fifth of the emissions from
burning fossil fuels every year
the latest research suggests that
without them the world would already be
nearly one degree celsius hotter we
can't solve climate change without
tropical forests but right now instead
of protecting forests we're cutting them
down
already about one-sixth of the amazon
has been lost and some scientists fear
that we're nearing a tipping point that
could mean loss of the entire forest
forests in indonesia and malaysia even
the vast forests of central africa are
under threat as well
and deforestation means carbon pollution
in fact tropical deforestation worldwide
accounts for almost as much emissions
as all the world's cars and trucks
combined
so losing tropical forests means losing
any hope
of limiting the rise in global
temperatures to one and a half or even
two degrees celsius
the heart of the problem is economic as
long as it's profitable to chop down
forests for timber or clear them for
agriculture we'll continue to lose them
now i'm not suggesting that we try to
halt capitalism in its tracks
we need to fix the market not abandon it
we need a new and better economic
development model for tropical forest
countries and that means
changing the incentives
so that forests are worth more alive
than dead if we can do that we will
drive investment into tropical forest
protection while also
producing the goods and services we need
this is the amazon forest in mato grosso
a brazilian state that's as large as
texas and a chunk of california combined
and one of the world's largest producers
of beef and soy
mato grosso is now a model of economic
development and
forest protection
but back in 2004 mato grosso was one of
the world's largest carbon polluters
entirely because of tropical
deforestation
since then deforestation is down over 85
percent
how
well mato grosso didn't reduce emissions
by shutting down agriculture instead
with support from the governments of
germany and norway it stepped up
enforcement against illegal land
grabbers it empowered local communities
and indigenous populations to protect
their territories it worked with
agricultural producers and traders
across the supply chain to invest in new
and more sustainable production methods
these efforts were supported by a broad
array of ngos and businesses and
indigenous organizations and they worked
so well
that when a new governor was elected in
2018 he immediately affirmed his
commitment to reducing deforestation and
continued the state's policies
because he saw how these new policies
were attracting new investment and
laying the foundation for sustainable
growth
if we're going to stave off climate
catastrophe the world needs many more
macho grossos
now mato grosso began its bold
experiment with public funding
but we need if we're going to preserve
and extend those gains and scale them up
to jurisdictions around the world we
need a new and more durable and much
larger source of forest finance
and the key to unlocking that finance
making forest worth more alive than dead
that means putting a value on standing
forests
in a way that channels new investment
hard cash
into sustainable green growth that
protects the forest while supporting the
livelihoods of people who live there
it's a development model that could make
brazil and indonesia and other forest
nations the world's first green
economic superpowers that allows them to
capture the full value of their natural
resources
this is the goal of the leaf coalition
leaf stands for lowering emissions by
accelerating forest finance
it's a coalition of 12 companies and
three countries that has committed one
billion dollars in finance for forest
protection at scale over the next five
years one of the largest ever public
private investments in forest protection
that first billion dollars will pay for
a hundred million tons of emissions
reductions with the prospect of many
more billions to come
i have a special connection to this
story because the idea that became leaf
was drawn up on a white board in my old
office at environmental defense fund
over eight years ago
now if i had been giving this talk then
it would have been purely theoretical
but that was before the full success of
mato grosso
and before the key building blocks that
made leaf possible were put into place
these three building blocks are
essential to any credible market
accurate measurement
a standard for quality and a platform
for transactions
first credible forest transactions
require accurate and precise measurement
and thanks to satellite
advances in satellite data and remote
sensing we can measure the amount of
carbon a forest contains and track
changes in real time
the second building block is a standard
for quality so that buyers of emissions
reductions can be certain they're
getting the real thing
at leaf we use a new approach that
focuses on the performance
not of individual forests but of entire
official jurisdictions like a state or
nation it builds in buffers against
risks like forest fire and it requires
countries forest nations to increase
their ambition over time
the third and final building block is a
platform for transactions
we created a financial intermediary
called emergent that connects sellers
forest nations that have emissions
reductions that they can sell with
buyers who include companies that are
looking to make good on their voluntary
climate commitments
you put those three building blocks
together
and you get a reliable and robust market
for forest carbon that enables economies
to thrive while protecting the forest
we know it's possible in mato grosso soy
production more than doubled and cattle
increased by over a quarter
even as deforestation plummeted
so the leaf model promises better
outcomes for forests
better outcomes for the people who live
there and better outcomes for the forest
nations as a whole
but you may be asking what's in it for
the companies
well now more than ever
companies see a business case for
climate action their customers are
demanding it their investors are so are
their employees
and companies recognize that truly
leading on climate
means doing two things
first
reducing emissions in their own
operations and supply chains and the
companies that are part of leaf
have all been required to set
science-based targets for their own
emissions
second they must contribute to the
broader fight
and one of the most important ways that
these companies or any company
can help solve climate change outside
their own operations and supply chains
is by protecting tropical forests
so that bears repeating companies in
leaf are investing in forest protection
over and above
what they're doing to reduce their own
emissions it's a it's not a substitute
it's a supplement
because if we're going to solve climate
change we need to achieve both
deep cuts in fossil fuel emissions and
dramatic reductions in forest emissions
it took over a decade to put all of the
building blocks in place that made leaf
possible
and the results so far are enormously
encouraging
in the next 10 years if we can expand
leaf globally
we can stop tropical deforestation
protect some of the largest carbon sinks
on the planet
and enable forest nations and local
populations to thrive and grow
all because we harness the power of the
market
to reflect the full value of standing
forests and make them worth more alive
than dead
thank you
you